[Music]
16:56 tre wet the deep three now it is
young with the three gray young man is
heating up decent soft touch there but
when he gets inside with that float
[Music]
long three four young cherish Eric
gorn's had a relatively quiet night
tonight yes he has and turns it over
this their prey got it off for young
with the hands when you stop from this
far out you've got space down another
three keep working to get in the paint
drink
[Applause]
that one
[Applause]
inclusive pick the no help there
the little too late my piccata winds
doing a good job a challenge in the bari
Parkers claims this rebound tre young
catch it shoot
tre young has already shown you what
makes it difficult
[Music]
he was two steps inside a half-court and
he's at the bottom of the circle on that
one ready with a great food nice little
call to where you going Josh you're an
almost from the logo it allows food for
one-on-one play with trained young is
exploiting right now
[Music]
boy downtown what's up you guys it's
Taylor Brooks with bleach to report make
sure that you subscribe for more video
content